Hale hunt Ange catch here and in this
tidy Tuesday video we're actually not
gonna look at the weekly Teddy trees a
dataset on which I believe is volcano
eruptions instead we're actually a look
at some UFC data because recently
there's been a UFC car that happened on
Saturday and I thought it'd be
interesting to implement an e low rating
system so equal rating system is
basically originated from chess where it
was a way to basically give people tiers
so when you beat someone you would gain
points if you lose and so on you'll lose
points it's kind of a good way to like
ranked teams and how they compare up to
each other and how they upset I'm each
other
so I'm 538 uses I guess they're a low
rankings especially for like their NBA
on the NFL predictions they kind of have
a nice a high level article about how
they do it so I thought it'd be
interesting to kind of implement a ehlo
system into UFC fighters so like which
fighter had the most upsets who's the
best fighter um in each weight class due
to their ego rating system and the
actual formula for e Glo is pretty
simple um it's kind of like uh I think
like a logistic kind of formula however
I didn't really feel I I didn't feel
like it'd be a good video for me to
implement that because I'm not really a
great programmer I'm more into the data
analysis stuff so I looked up an e low
package and there actually isn't you a
package which will basically do it for
us and it's pretty basic it it's kind of
like a I'm your typical formula so it's
like win for Team a and they use team a
plus team B and they give it the data
set with a specific K factor so we're
gonna do that um I recommend just
downloading this book or you can
probably look on it might I choose a
repo one thing that we should be looking
at is so for 538 they use a cave 20 and
this basically shows how quickly their
ratings are reactive to
games okay so I'm gonna open up a our
markdown file I'll I'll put this into a
github document I'm gonna make sure to
go to my tight Tuesday I'm gonna set us
working directory okay something call is
tidy Tuesday UFC Ehlo okay move that
library tidy verse and when we look at
the actual was it called a colonel from
cattle we're just gonna use the data dot
CSV which is like the cleaned up dataset
so yeah we're just gonna put that in
okay let's do that
so TF read CSV and it's called data dot
CSV so we're gonna do that first we're
gonna look at the column names and if we
see here this is kind of like a thing
you probably find in an excel style
format where it's just it's not an
entirety format as basically it's
basically two tables an opponent and a
fighter table combined like see bind
together so we're gonna have to clean
this up
even though umm the EO package actually
wants it in this format where it just
wants the fighter fighter a fighter b
and the actual results but we want to
use this we want to convert this into a
tidy format just because it's a tie
Tuesday and it'll be probably easier for
future analysis so if you wanted to do
more charts or dashboards it's probably
easier to put in a tidy format okay so
if you notice there's two sets of
features basically they're where it's an
R and a B which is I think the red in
the blue corner so we're gonna make a
red D F and a ludia right so that way
we'll just have them kind of split okay
so first we're gonna figure out a way to
select all of the red corner
attributes or features so one cool way
we can do this is just do the Select at
function okay so we're gonna select I
have any VARs or variables that starts
with R okay so when we do that we can
see okay we got a lot of that we have
all that stuff
and we're just gonna do column names
first just so we can kind of get a
better look at to what we need okay so
we have what we need for that that's
very specific to the R however we also
want to get the the winner or the result
of it okay so what we're also going to
do is um we're gonna find VARs or
variables that starts with R and we're
also gonna grab the variable that has
the word winner in it okay so now we
have winner cool what CEOs what would we
need to do um
so once we have these these columns we
don't really want these are on the
scores right because we're gonna
essentially our Bynum or just like kind
of stack the red and the blue corner
well into the same data set so we need
to do is first a rename all these
feature all these up variables and we
can do the rename all and since we know
that all these variables have the string
our honor score we're gonna remove that
string from it okay so that's just a
simple function and we're gonna use the
dot funds or dot function and this is
basically a helper function for it so
function X and then you know it's the
classic STR replace the string that
we're gonna implementing is the column
name which in this case it's gonna be
called X the pattern will be our
underscore and the replacement when we
just oh uh blank space okay so see that
we dropped everything that we needed
okay
boom additionally what we need to do is
kind of have like a match a match ID
because if we look at this it's fighter
versus fighter B but we don't actually
have a match and we could you say let's
here we could use something else like I
think we could use a date
where's data names we could use date as
it but I don't think that's a great idea
um I don't especially since a date will
be kind of different for each person so
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
create our own primary key or like match
ID in this case we're just gonna do a
mutate and say match ID equals row
number okay that's fine we can do that
because we're basically splitting it in
half so and each row already is a unique
match additionally this also solves a
problem with um fires fighting each
other I'm having rematch with each other
so we couldn't just say Oh a unique ID
is when fighter R and fighter B are
fighting together when in reality you
know they might have a another fight in
the future and that might cause some
problems okay so now that we have this
we're gonna call this the RDF for the
red corner and we're gonna use the same
thing with the blue corner okay in this
case we can kind of do this right
because it's just doing the opposite
with only B's okay
so we can go as PDF okay lastly there
there are some features that we know are
the same for every for this for each
fighters fight for example they have the
same referee date location um title bout
weight class number of rounds etc okay
so I'm gonna just do a brief skim and
notice I always
our or be on the top so I'm going to
assume that's unique to that fighter so
we're gonna say we're gonna create a
shared features kind of data set and
we'll just say select a referee day
location location location title about
weight class number of rounds in
addition what we have to do is you have
to mutate and say match ID equals um
equals a row number right so that way we
can add them together technically we
could just do a C bind with the shared
features however um this kind of
prevents some things from getting messed
up okay so shared features right match
ID referee date everything looks normal
finally we're gonna create our tidy data
frame but if you notice if we select the
rdf and select winner as red blue and
yada right with the iwo package um they
count winds as dependent on just one
fighter okay so if you look at what see
where's a so a win is a one at eyes at
0.5 and a loss is a zero and when's that
a is is equipment teamed at home so i've
team if the home team a wins it's a one
if home team loses it's a 0 which means
the visitor want right it's kind of a
degrees of freedom by nor anything so
what we're gonna have to do is decide
who or we gonna say is the home team and
in this case i'm just gonna say the home
team is mean it's gonna be red okay so
what we're gonna have to do is rdf okay
mutate and we'll say winner equals case
one
okay and then say if winter equals red
that means it's a win-win turn equals
blue that means it's a loss and then
else or true um it's a point five for a
tie Oh point five for a time okay so we
get that and if we do the count winner
we can see that there are fifteen
hundred and losses eighty-three ties and
3471 wins kind of odd that um I guess I
don't know I don't know if red corner
blue corner
I've have specific arrangements where if
your favor you're on the red corner but
you can see that to working at least
okay so we're gonna do the same thing
with the we're gonna do actually not the
same thing with the blue corner because
in this case if the blue corner at the
blue corner if winner equals red for the
blue corner that means they lost right
um so we're gonna just swish it around
okay so now we fixed that
and finally what we're gonna do is we're
gonna Stu are buying this so we're gonna
be stacking together so I'm gonna copy
this thing in copy this guy in
Oh copy this guy in okay and now we
stack them together lastly since now we
have basically a fighter table so that
this is Henry cejudo kudos on stats for
this fight so all this stuff you know
the fight data for that specific match
whether he won or not but we wanted to
have you know the date all at the date
the referee location weight class number
of rounds stuff like that so we're going
to do a left join shared features by
equals match ID okay so if we go back
right here we have that we have our day
and stuff like that okay so we're gonna
call this the tied EDF because has all
this stuff that we needed let's see what
else do we need to do yeah I think it
has everything we needed so we're gonna
do that
tidy F call them names just to make sure
everything looks good yeah I think
everything looks great and I'm not
really gonna go too much you can do this
I just kind of want to implement the elo
system and uh maybe we'll look at this
data set again later but let's see here
let's go on so now since we have a our
tidy data frame um we need a basically
untidy it for let's sit for the Ehlo
right so we can do it in two ways on one
hand we could just not use our tidy data
frame and just use this rdf right here
or we could we could just do the use the
after tight a frame
I think well I'm gonna do is let's here
I think I'm just gonna do it with the
tidied a-frame because it'll be easier
right so we already have our clean names
we can just say select just will be
fighter um fighter um winter match ID
and then we'll see weight class and date
right and then what we're gonna do is
we're going to do a left join using the
same tight a frame but instead we're
gonna select fighter and match ID right
I'm gonna join it by by equals match I
do okay so right here we have fighter
winter match ID yadda yadda
notice how Fighter EX fire that why and
we'd see a problem here work we have the
same fighter right see how's Henry
cejudo vs. Henry cejudo that can't
happen so we're gonna say is we're in
our first rename um will say fighter
equals Fighter X and then we'll say
opponent equals fighter Y right
then actually and then we're gonna do a
filter where fighter cannot equal the
opponent there you go so now we have
10,000 rows of our fighter and stuff
like that and just to do a sanity check
DF dim okay what else did we do oh do
you have Tim yeah that makes sense does
that make sense yes it and they're two
counts actually oh I got an idea
and then it's gonna do a range my match
ID okay right here so we still have well
guess that's what I was saying it didn't
make any sense
so we can see how we have duplicate
fighters because even though they're
fighting different people these guys are
swapped with each other okay so one way
to do this is we're just gonna do a
group by um match ID all right so we're
gonna group by each match ID and we're
just gonna select the first one okay and
we're gonna ungroup it and now if we do
it it'll be fifty one forty four okay
and we're gonna call this the ehlo data
frame yeah you will yeah so now that we
have reload data frame we can actually
use the evil package so yo and I when I
was testing the he little package I also
found that the room package works with
it so that's all we're gonna do so if we
do the evil package doesn't really have
that many um commands so you can do some
tweaking z' to it but in reality it
doesn't only have too much stuff so it
just has a little fake data set scores
rankings players stuff like that we're
just gonna use the e low run because
this basically simulates the actual
games that happen okay
in this case we're gonna use winter and
it'll be fighter + opponent and you have
to specify a k for it so we'll say k
equals 20 because if we look at the 538
package at 5 538 article they said that
they use a K of 20 and they say this is
higher than we expect it is in the same
range as K it was used for NFL and
international soccer so for all three
sports they basically used the same K
now I don't think soccer
I don't think UFC is a similar support
to those sports but it's a good baseline
at leas so then we give it a data set so
ego GF we do it so it creates an object
you'll don't run and we're gonna call us
Evo
okay so now what we're gonna do is after
you gonna come with this so we're gonna
say yeah and now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna actually rank the teams so
we're gonna use the rank that teams
function and you see that it ranks
everyone so but it puts in a kind of a
bad bad way I took uh was it Old West or
whatever
luckily um we can use the broom package
as tidy function to just make it into a
tidy format let's see so so it has a
ranking right here and the names right
there Oh actually what's here I totally
forgot I'm gonna zoom in a little bit
that's my bad I'm gonna zoom in a little
bit I tore out that I write a comment
last week but we haven't done too much
yet so you know we have it zoomed in a
little bit so we have it tidied we're
gonna rename um we're gonna rename the
x2 ranking ranking Google X and then we
can just do a arrange by ranking okay so
what do we see here um what we see is
that the elope ranking actually makes
sense so if you know about you left see
stuff you can see that Jon Jones and GSP
are ranked very high which um actually
um last you a si card on GSP actually I
inducted to the USC Hall of Fame so this
is starting to make a lot of sense it's
interesting that Tony Ferguson is ranked
three Demetrius probably because he
actually I bet why I bet Tony Ferguson
is wearing so high is because he's he's
gone on a huge win streak so he hasn't
lost any low for a long time Dimitri's
Johnson is pretty high even though he
doesn't fight anymore
Donald Cerrone again is pretty high um
okay cool so one problem I guess with
the this evil thing is that it's not
accounting for these weight classes
right so
John Jones will never face like
Demetrius Johnson okay so it's kind of
hard for you to really rank them
together so we're gonna have to do is
[Music]
we're gonna have to base it do a we're
gonna have to make these evil rankings
for each weight class okay so that's
what we're gonna do ello DF trying to
think the best way to do this
yeah we'll create a function to find the
top to find ya to basically do this to
find the top ten ranked people ranked
fighters for each weight class okay so
that's what we're gonna say where is it
low top function data and we're just
going to put this into this will call
this results yeah and then we'll say
ranked up teams results tidy ranking
arranged and we don't you need to do the
arrange will say filter ranking is less
than equal to 10 so it will return a
list right here of the rankings for each
weight class okay cool so we did that so
we're gonna do is we're going to use the
e low DF and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say a group by weight class
I'm some weight class
and then we're going to use the nest
function so now we have a little table
of data for each weight class and then
what we're gonna do is we're gonna say
oh let's say ranking equals and we're
gonna map this function e low top or see
you okay map a low top to it so ello
what was a map and then we give it a
data
and a function so we're gonna input this
little subset of data for the weight
class for each class into this function
so what it's going to say is
so for Bantam weight we're going to take
the Bantam weight data find the top 10
and put it into a table cool so now we
have a list of 10 I'm gonna assume you
don't say that but we can understand we
gotta Nesta was it let's hear what okay
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
select weight class and ranking and
we're gonna unnecessary ins and I'm
gonna say arranged by ranking and then
weight class all right so it's a little
bit whoa what's going on here oh there
we go so we had to do that so we see
here we had we had a specified data
equals data there we go so now we have
it and this is making sense GSP best
Walter right
welterweight Tony first and best
lightweight John Jones best light
heavyweight Junior dos Santos okay yeah
yeah these make sense going excellen--
bans away number two is TJ Dillashaw I'm
not sure I Chris cyber is here I think
there might be a male course I'm cyborg
not sure why that's there might be a
little data issue but
so that's making sense okay but one
thing that we got it we can't need to
figure out is how can we find the best I
guess
eel oh all right how can you find the
best eel oh for 4k how can you specs
decide kay okay so that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna say what's here
we'll we'll say um k sensitivity so okay
sensitive to case oh say sense
k sense okay function okay and we're
basically gonna do the same thing with
ego top however for in this case we're
just gonna do this for the overall
rankings we can kind of specify this as
like a pound for pound ranking again we
could do it on the nested data and see
how that works but I think it's probably
a little bit better to make it more of
an overall thing instead of making its
best specified for each weight class
again there's something where it's
pretty I think it's pretty subjective
but just for simplicity's sake we're
gonna do for the overall thing the
overall I guess pound for pound fast
fight or whatever so we have this case
sense range and we'll say instead we're
gonna do filter ranking is less than
equal to ten in this case we're gonna
give it the same data frames because we
don't need to do the weight class thing
so we're gonna do that
and now what we're essentially gonna do
is make kind of like a grid search okay
so we'll say K rankings table K equals
sequence from equals 1/2 equals 101 5
equals 10 this saying is we're gonna
make a basically we're gonna test out
different case from like 1 to 100 1 by
10 so it's 1 11:21
yada okay and I believe with when we
look at it again so k
okay I believe that higher the K the
more sensitive these scores are okay so
if K set you high the rate your ratings
will jump around too much case - well
it'll it'll fail to meet the outflow
changes so it'll be too slow so that's
we're gonna do so we have our whatever
our optimal case or the case that we
want to test now what we're gonna do is
just gonna do a simple me tape and say
ranking these goals map k and then k
okay sense right and then we can just do
a simple uh nest
and yeah
so we have our rankings I'm gonna assign
it to this and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna ggplot it out so GD plot x
equals names y equals k fill equals
ranking plus geum tile plus scored flip
okay we probably have to do a reorder
let's see here
I'll just do a mutate we'll do a group
by names summer actually mutate mutate
average rank equals mean was it ranking
ungroup and then we'll say reorder names
by their average ranking average rank
okay um and we'll say - so top the purse
on top has on average the highest
ranking okay so let's see here let's go
down put that so what are we seeing here
so the people who we can see something
so the higher that K or the more
sensitive the rankings are you can see
how Anderson Silva benefit
from a highly volatile okay we can see
with GSP a slower K means he's higher
ranked and we can also see how some
people just drop off of the top 10
rankings okay so what I'm looking at
this I actually think the best K is
probably maybe around this range and the
reason why I think that is because all
these people um
it fits the most were these people who I
would consider the best there are some
problems but I think I'm not sure if Max
halwa is you know the top 10 greatest
fighter of all time well I think he's a
great fighter so I'm not I'm not sure
it's it's kind of subjective right one
thing that I would say is I don't think
Tony Ferguson now would be considered
the best fighter over say Kamara Wiesman
so McDonald Cerrone I don't think Donald
Cerrone is the best fighter so you can
see like oh if I don't want Donald
Cerrone as a ranked fighter or two
ranked top 10 fighter of all time I
would probably want to do a higher K
right so maybe maybe it might be
actually higher okay I'm not sure I'm
you can see yellow khabib he he
increases with a higher okay and I think
could be he's one of the best fighters
right so maybe maybe might be I have to
it it might have to have a higher K on
that kind of makes sense because with
MMA and UFC it's a volatile sport we're
in one second the champion who's been
fighting 17 fights and has never lost
could get knocked out in 20 seconds okay
oh yeah so that's just kind of a thing
just to look at how sensitivity or how K
affects rankings and overall okay so we
have all this stuff we have all this
like rankings we've figured out the
rankings with a given K of 24 on each
weight class but it'd be kind of
interesting to look at the actual kilo
history of it right Howie lo changes and
we we actually look at our Evo right if
you go to Iwo and then we do kind of a
look at you oh and I think we can what
if we can tidy it I don't think we do it
so we have to do it as
frame but it actually does show you that
you will history we're saying team a
team B P of a wins update okay so it's
like each each each person's you will
and probably ability of winning one
thing that we got to do is we got to
rename this stuff so I'm gonna rename
I'm not sure how to do this both fast
but we can just do it really we just do
it right now so Honan equals to fighter
prob equals three fighter wins equal
fighter fighter wins equals I guess for
fighter oops
ego change equals five equals 600 0
equals oh eight and then I forgot to do
equals seven what's you oh okay so we
have it renamed fighter opponent fighter
prob Yatta Yatta okay so how are we
gonna do this okay we gotta we need a
put in a HISP
kind of figure out a way to do this okay
so we have the overall history of this
but we need to do is I want to find the
history for each weight class where the
eloah is specific for each weight class
okay
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna call this yellow history and we're
gonna create this into a function passed
along on data so results yellow dot run
winner fighter plus opponent and k k
equals we'll say yeah now that I'm
looking at this I kind of want to have a
higher case we're going to use a K of 60
K of 60 K of 60 and then data equals
data and now we're gonna pass this thing
into it say results results as it okay
do that the ODF one thing that we got to
do is we got to think how can we match
these match IDs consid we notice when we
do the actual Evo uod um evil it's we it
it removes the actual match IDs right
and since we're gonna be grouping it or
messing it by a by weight class what
we're gonna do is we're gonna just kind
of make sure that it doesn't get
scrambled so we're gonna rearrange the
weight class and slider so we're gonna
arrange by sort by weight class and for
every way Clause we're gonna sort by its
fighters okay so that way it's gonna be
a little bit in a better order okay and
then once a group by group by weight
class and dude nest mutate and we'll say
history equals math data and then Ehlo
history
right and we notice that okay we have
mismatched links for data frames because
there are you know there probably more
Bantam weights I think catch weight
isn't even a thing anymore so that makes
sense so it's starting to make sense
we're gonna select weight class history
uh nest ungroup cool and we have it nope
see how we have it's in alphabetical
order by weight class and then my
fighter that's good
we're actually gonna see bind
we're see bind this was it you OD f
arranged and with a low D F we're just
gonna see bind the select we're gonna
select the match ID because that's all
we won't really want to grab for it so
now we have the match ID for it and what
we're gonna call us is élow changes
because we want to we're base trying to
find out the fighters evo change
throughout that their entire career okay
so what do we need to do if we know it
is something it's kind of in the non
tidy format that we don't want right so
we're gonna have to do the same thing
that we did last time where we're gonna
basically separate separate them by the
fighter data and the opponent data and
then combine them at the end okay and
this is something where I technically
could put it in this function but I'm
not sure if that's a good way to do it
or not it is also kind of a one-time
thing but that's all we're gonna do so
what we're gonna have to do is select
weight class fighter fighter prob
fighter wins
fighter eloah change fighter ii well and
match i do okay so this is the fighter
data set we're just gonna leave that
there and then just to reference it I'm
gonna say ego changes select weight
class opponent opponent and then we if
you know something we don't have the
opponent problem right um but since we
know we have the fighter problem we can
say the compliment right compliment so
like one - it so that's we're gonna say
we're just say fighter problem again
fighter problem and then fighter wins
which in this case fighter wins is is an
actually number it's more of like a
category so fire wins means this person
will lost this match so we're gonna have
to change that to and then we'll say a
ponent ego change and then a hone in
evil and then match ID so there's
there's some things that we can change
first so we can say fighter equals
opponent and we can say fighter ii low
change equals that let me say fighter
you go Eagles that okay what's going on
here oh there we go
fighter yo and the fighter you all
equals opponent you long so we have that
but we got to do some just some slight
changes so we have to say mutate fighter
oops
mutate fighter prop equals one minus
fighter
where that makes sense see we have the
inverse of that same matches see a match
thirteen seventeen sixty percent
thirteen seventeen forty percent right
and we have to do a fighter wins equals
and we'll just do a can another case one
statement and say fighter wins pools to
was it equals away was it equals equals
um I forgot this that's here finally and
equals yeah I was right okay equals one
then they lost fighter wins equals zero
then they won um true then it was a draw
right and that makes sense so now we
have that we have this and what we can
do now is we can just see our bind it so
we'll say are mine I'm all kind of paste
this guy in there we'll paste this guy
in there and it works out finally we had
the e low change in the match ID we can
also do a left join all right with our
what so is that we can we can left join
our tidy dataframe and we'll say by
equals by equals and then in this case
since our type if we look at this let's
just put this in there we need to join
it we know we have the match idea right
but each match ID has a different
fighter right each each match ID has a
different fighter so what we're gonna
have to do is we're not joined by match
ID and fighter additionally what I
noticed is fighter is a factor so what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna put it
right here so fight
equals as a character fighter edition
yeah right yeah that's good so we're
gonna say tight data frame and we're
gonna join by match ID oops
and fighter so I work yeah that works
sweet and one thing that I didn't
realize this until probably like a few
days ago but you don't actually have to
say match ID equals match ID as long as
they have the same call names for the
two tables you can just specify it like
this okay so this is our final Ehlo
changes data set a way actually we got
to do some renaming let's here see the
weight weight loss dot X is changed so
we got a deselect some stuff so select -
weight class dot y rename weight class
equals weight class dot X anything else
going on not seeing anything and no no
more no more dot X is a doll wise okay
just checking again looks fine cool so
that's our final eloah changes you go
changes right it's folio changes okay
so we have our kilo changes each fighter
has a has their little there attribute
fighter attributes the match attributes
their opponent attributes for that match
um also their fighter probability of
winning the amount of wins they had
their ego change okay so that's that's a
that's pretty represent that's like a
pretty you know nice dataset to have
when doing some type of analysis so what
we can do is we can just filter out
let's say um the fighter equals and in
this case I'm gonna do a Henry cejudo
right because Henry sees so who'd oh
just retired cool yeah it's here yeah
whenever winner when your loss against
okay okay so what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna GGG plot this out so
date wykel's Fighter II well what's
going on here oh I bet just that I think
that date so mutate date equals a Zadeh
day cool plus genome and now we can see
Henry cejudo Zoar so kudos Evo change
right very nice yeah so let's hear one
cool thing about you lo is that if we
look at our Ehlo changes and we kind of
do like top and you Fighter II low and
then N equals five you can see the top
five people so right here these guys
have the highest elos um regardless of
fights so i each time they're getting
better and better right what else
how else can we do this so we can
one way to do this we can say a group by
a fire
um top top and a fighter
buttery low and then fight at you Oh an
equals one on group and then top and
fighter helo and equals five right so
that way it's saying like what was the
best for every fighter we're gonna use
their best eat low score and then out of
that we're gonna find who has a top top
five e low scores right so then see it
makes sense John Jones Brian Bader
I think Ryan Bader [ __ ] old-school
guys I I'm not as familiar with him Matt
Hughes JSP 21st okay so those are top
fires obviously you can use the the
other thing with the e low on top
fighters but one thing that would be
interesting is since we have our Evo
scores we can also look at like the
probabilities okay
and since we have our élow data set
right here we can also just do basic
predictions so if we say um let's see
what what's a good head-to-head that we
would say um yeah I got an idea so
previously in the last card we had
dominant cruisers Henry say who don't so
that's that's the thing we should say
look how how would our um scores fare up
against the probabilities for each
fighters win-win probability right okay
if I wanted to bet on it and I have all
this data what's estimate how likely you
know Dominick Cruz would win or
Henrietta who dough we can say predict
you will and we just got to give it a
data frame so we got to give it fighter
equals and we'll say Henry cejudo who
don't and then Conant equals Dominick
Cruz
right and it gives you a probability of
hiring Takuto beating them it gives
Henry - hoo-hoo - a 52 percent chance of
beating him and what's interesting is
who did beat him alright cool so that's
something that's pretty cool why
obviously John Jones and GSP are in
different way classes but you know it'd
be kind of interesting to see could John
Jones beat GSP so let's do that right 50
50 percent chance now obviously they're
in different weight classes and that
definitely probably has a some type of
effect however you could definitely add
that into a model right so you could
just do your fighter ii low scores right
with the weight class and then factor it
in right that that's a pretty easy
feature engineering to go there so you
could do some type of you know
interaction effect with weight class or
weight class differences stuff like that
cool finally let's find out who has that
the biggest upset right who had the
biggest upset or what war the biggest
upsets so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna select we're going to find the top
end and we'll say absolute fighter ego
change right and then we're gonna say
arranged by absolute fighter kilo change
okay was top man hopes and we'll say N
equals 5 so if we notice here these are
the same things right so what we're
gonna have to do is uh what's a year oh
I got an idea
who see this is probably from the same
this is from the same fight so what
we're gonna have to do is let's here you
go change and then we'll say group by
match id slice 1
I'm group and then we'll say top and
absolute Fighter II blow change n equals
five
all right and then arranged by
descending order our fighter you love
change sweet cool yeah let's let's see
the actual thing so fighter Tito Ortiz
he had a fight probability of seven
percent of winning Nate Diaz had a 14
percent chance of winning stuff like
that I'm one thing that I probably would
want is say let's select match ID and
then like left join with I guess Evo
yeah so that we have a little better
represented you know a cleaner format
okay cool sweep yeah so this was
basically the UFC data set you know just
kind of went over you know kind of how
to use these kind of functions helper
functions and how to basically use them
to do a grid search use the mapping for
it and kind of also learn more about and
having fun with like Evo and it's
applications in sports so yeah hopefully
I'll see you as next week and tidy on